tutti amici di te dx io sono qui
allarme della mia professione di
interprete di canzoni mi chiamo arisa il
mio nome d'arte arisa ma in realtà mi
chiamo rosalba e sono molto molto
contenta di poter fare questa cosa
perché per me è una prova
e soprattutto perché mi piace
diciamo approcciarmi a voi in una
maniera diversa
dopo tutto questo periodo che abbiamo
avuto anche per sperimentare le nostre
capacità e buona parte di questo periodo
io l'ho dedicata proprio a questo specie
perché ci teniamo particolarmente a
parlarvi del retroscena della mia
professione dei retroscena della mia
professione
infatti il tema è behind e shin su che
cosa fa un interprete
quando scende dal palco quindi quali
sono i retroscena della professione
dell'interprete musicale allora sappiamo
tutti che il cantautore è colui che
canta le sue canzoni quelle che scrive
mentre l'interprete è colui che canta le
canzoni di altri
molti pensano che addirittura un
interprete sia solo un mezzo e in alcuni
casi lo è perché soprattutto per quanto
riguarda componimenti del passato
l'interprete di cemon si adatta a quello
che è il sentimento dell'originale però
sicuramente sceglie di cantare una data
canzone perché nonostante possa essere
assolutamente intoccabile
comunque lo riguarda in qualche modo in
generale l'interprete soprattutto per
quanto riguarda i suoi nuovi progetti e
il suo rapporto con
con la comunicazione e con gli
interlocutori della sua comunicazione è
molto pragmatico nel senso che comunque
fare delle cose
affinché la sua interpretazione possa
essere fluida e credibile al di là del
fatto che una canzone sia potuta
arrivare da un'altra persona
io in realtà oggi voglio parlarvi di me
perché io la la professione
dell'interprete degli altri non le
conosco
senonché per biografie che riguardano
più la vita di interpreti che hanno
fatto la storia della musica mondiale
però quello che mi colpisce è sempre una
sorta di emotività cioè quindi quello
che so dell'interprete è qualcosa più
legato alla persona ecco mentre
tecnicamente io vorrei cercare di
raccontarvi di quella che è la mia
esperienza cioè come mi preparo al
lavoro di interprete da un punto di
vista fisico e da un punto di vista
anche spirituale perché considerando che
gli interpreti sono uno strumento e
lavorano attraverso se stessi
effettivamente è giusto che alimentino
tutta la loro sfera vitale quindi quella
emotiva e quella fisica
cominciamo subito a parlare per quanto
mi riguarda sempre della dell'esperienza
fisica della propria la preparazione
fisica
l'interprete un po come un atleta
appunto perché abbiamo detto utilizza
tutto il corpo per
per formare e sicuramente necessita di
uno allenamento fisico quindi aerobico
per produrre resistenza e riuscire a
sostenere i ritmi molto molto incalzanti
che questo lavoro premette e poi
adeguate se un adeguato esercizio per le
corde vocali che consiste per esempio in
esercizi non le solite scale oppure può
consistere in versi completamente
diciamo avulsi si può dire da
dall'attività della del bel canto però
diciamo che tutto ci aiuta a sviluppare
le nostre capienze le capienze che
riguardano la nostra maschera da dove
esce il suono ecco vabbè questi sono
discorsi troppo tecnici nei quali non mi
voglio soffermare troppo anche perché
non ho tanto tempo
però effettivamente il viaggio che si
affronta durante la conoscenza della
propria voce e davvero intrigante è
davvero appagante anche sotto un punto
di vista di consapevolezza di noi stessi
di conoscerci sotto un punto di vista
molto molto più intimo e molto molto più
inconsapevole le emozioni esplode le
mozioni esplode e si concretizza
in un canto in un canto che
l'espressione di noi stessi e come se
noi avessimo ogni volta attraverso la
possibilità di cantare una canzone un
pittore che dipinge che ci dipinge
quindi è molto molto importante
a pagare la nostra parte emotiva ma dare
la possibilità alla nostra parte motiva
di esprimersi attraverso una forma
fisica che rispecchi il perfetto
funzionamento delle nostre doti canore e
fisiche quindi fisiche appunto vi dicevo
da un punto di vista spirituale
effettivamente è molto importante per
un'interprete riuscire ad empatizzare ad
immedesimarsi per fare questo appunto
anche lì deve conoscersi alla perfezione
quindi deve dedicare molto tempo a se
stesso e questo sicuramente ha dei pro e
dei contro
se da un lato
riesce a conoscersi a curarsi le ferite
a instaurare un rapporto con se stesso
appagante ecco dall'altro comunque la
socialità viene penalizzata e le
esperienze almeno che non riguardino
strettamente quelle interiori sono
meno soprattutto poi con la vita degli
adulti insomma e con la cadenza degli
eventi che siamo abituati a vivere tutti
i giorni ma che riguardano un poco la
sfera emotiva in realtà riguardano più
il successo la voglia di varcare delle
nuove porte di strappare dei traguardi
[Musica]
mentre quella che è da risvegliare è
qualcosa che ricordi al nostro bambino
interiore che siamo ancora vicini a lui
e quindi la parte emotiva deve occuparsi
di risvegliare il nostro bambino
interiore che è colui che comunque
stimola la nostra creatività e come
possiamo farlo questo prima di tutto
cercando di essere attenti al mondo che
ci circonda
riuscire a comprendere le cose dando una
spiegazione tra virgolette a se stessi
oggettiva e pulita
penso che se anche molto utile per
esempio appuntare i propri pensieri
cioè le cose che si notano per esempio
io oggi vedo gli alberi davanti alla mia
finestra che sono insolitamente di un
verde più tenue allora questa cosa io me
la scrivo non perché debba riportarla in
una canzone per forza ma perché
l'immagine che resta scrivendo
soprattutto è un'immagine che farà sì
che la l'energia del ricordo rimanga
dentro di noi
duke ellington un po di tempo fa scrisse
in realtà disse in un'intervista che lui
aveva utilizzato praticamente facendo un
esempio l'energia che avrebbe utilizzato
per fare il broncio per scrivere blues
cosa significa questo che se noi ci
appropriamo delle emozioni attraverso
cioè se noi fissiamo le emozioni che
proviamo quelle emozioni rimarranno
fonte del nostro cassetto emotivo e le
cose le idee creano le cose quindi
riusciremo a riconoscere uno stato
d'animo e riusciremo a farlo nostro ea
rendere la performance credibile reale
perché considerando che siamo tutti
interconnessi
non posso emozionarvi e non suscitare
emozione non possa innamorarmi di te se
tu non homage a me cioè queste sono cose
che dovrei approfondire soprattutto
potrei consigliarvi un libro che che
spiega questa cosa che si chiama
l'intelligenza emotiva di daniel coleman
intelligenza emotivo intelligenza
sociale comunque controllate e poi anche
altri studi mi hanno aiutato ad
avvalorare questa tesi
da quando sono capitata nelle tra le
pagine
del corso di creatività di julia cameron
la via dell'artista che consiglia di
abbandonarsi alle tre pagine del mattino
cioè ogni mattina per un po di tempo
l'ho fatto ho compilato queste tre
pagine del mattino e mi sono resa conto
che effettivamente con pincha
compilandole che sembra che io stia
compilando una multa però compilando
queste pagine del mattino scrivendo
scrivendo scrivendo senza nessuna logica
di significato o di punteggiatura o di
senso non lo so di di bellezza no
lessicale effettivamente succede
qualcosa in noi di estremamente
liberatorio riflessivo anche quando noi
pensiamo di avercela su con un'altra
persona mettere le idee per iscritto le
nostre sensazioni perché a volte siamo
soprattutto noi donne noi donne siamo
molto molto spumeggianti anche nei
nostri stati d'animo
ci sono delle cose che sopportiamo per
tanto tempo poi arriva un certo punto
che non siamo più in grado di sopportare
quindi quello che succede
più o meno simile a quando togliamo il
tappo a una bella bottiglia di champagne
e che è stata precedentemente agitata o
una lattina di coca cola
ecco quindi per esempio da un punto di
vista pratico a me queste tre pagine del
mattino ma anche aiutato per diventare
più riflessiva rispetto agli eventi cioè
descrivendoli rileggendoli
effettivamente ci si fa un'idea delle
cose
la riflessione ci dà energia quindi un
interprete ha bisogno di energia
empatica ha bisogno di energia che viene
prodotta dalle emozioni e questo è
praticamente il senso di nutrire la
nostra anima
cioè riuscire ad emozionarci riuscire a
non abbandonarci alla scontatezza e
alla pigrizia ma cercare sempre di
trovare un senso altro questo ci aiuterà
nella nostra professione di interpreti
ma anche nella nostra professione di
esseri umani
quindi non ho detto tutto ma ho detto
abbastanza
quello che ci tengo a dire che nel 2006
ho frequentato il centro europeo di
toscolano l'accademia di mogol
grazie una borsa di studio e sono stata
felicissima di
approcciarmi alla professione
dell'interprete perché l'interprete è
davvero una sorta di essere che dona se
stesso alla comunicazione c'è qualcosa
comunica se stesso vuole comunicare il
messaggio
se voi
osserverete bene nonostante l'essere
camaleontico di un interprete
quali sono le sue esternazioni di se
stesso attraverso quello che fa ci
troverete sempre degli elementi coerenti
e quegli elementi coerenti sono
destinati al pubblico che lui ama
naturalmente non conosco bene le altre
attività all'interno della musica ma
posso parlare della mia e mi sento
veramente molto fortunata a fare questo
lavoro e ma ciao a tutti amici di te dic
spero di essere risultata interessante
che abbia saputo catturare la vostra
attenzione
vi mando un abbraccio e vi auguro tempi
migliori e a presto